peter i'm gonna leave you with one thing
you almost said it earlier i could read
your mind you and i have this connection
i can read your mind
once bitcoin broke 42 thousand dollars
i know that you know
and think that it's going higher
gold is not going to go higher this year
please
please
please
buy some bitcoin just buy it well worst
case if it doesn't work hold on worst
case if it doesn't work
then you can say
my kid did it pomp did it all my other
friends did it i just wanted to have the
entertainment of losing money alongside
them but if it works
you'll send me a christmas card at the
end of the year and tell me thank you
yeah so peer pressure you think that's
gonna that's gonna get me together do
you think today we're sitting at 46 000
look me square in the eye and tell me
you don't think bitcoin's going to be
higher at the end of the year
look higher than it is today look i
don't know i mean look
but there are a lot of things that i
think could be higher at the end of the
year that's what i'm buying you know i i
want to buy stuff that i have confidence
in i want to buy stuff with real value
you know i buy businesses that pay me
good dividend income you know i i don't
want to just gamble on on bitcoin sure
it could go up but you know what let's
say i buy it and it goes up what if i
don't sell it and then it goes down and
i didn't even make any money even though
it went up i hope i held on to it i
followed your advice i bought it i held
onto it and then it crashed so even
though it went up who cares so i don't
want to you know play in that sandbox
with you guys you know if you put five
percent if you put five percent of your
net worth in bitcoin you'll become a
billionaire and then i can run around
and tell everyone i made peter ship a
billionaire you want me to put five
percent of my net worth in bitcoin to
make you a billionaire no
pomp made peter schiff a billionaire
after he buys bitcoin that's gonna be
the story no problem at all you know how
you know how to make a fortune in
bitcoin no i don't know you know how to
make a small fortune in bitcoin
what
start out with a large fortune yeah
i don't i don't want to do that i mean
look i don't need to get rich in bitcoin
i'm rich enough you know so um but i
don't want to go broke and i think that
if i put you know well obviously if i
put a you know a five percent i'm not
gonna go broke okay so then put five
percent you'll be a billionaire and then
you'll send me a christmas card there's
i just don't believe there's any way
that's going to happen
i mean
i i don't think bitcoin could bitcoin go
up from here sure
can it go to a million i think the odds
of that are so minimal right i know
everybody just assumes that it's going
to go up there everybody that owns it
that's why they're not selling
peter schiff said there's a possibility
bitcoin may go to a million dollars no i
don't think he will i think the odds are
that you know i mean maybe if the if
there's hyperinflation and a gallon of
gas is a million dollars maybe it could
happen right like anything is possible
but in real terms that's not gonna
happen but you know i've never seen
a
asset class
where the people that were invested
had such strong conviction as to how
much it was going to go up
right and so it's very rare
that everybody turns out to be that
right i mean you have so many people
that are in bitcoin and are so confident
that they are going to get rich that
they're going to be millionaires or
billionaires all they have to do is hold
on to this asset
um you know
people the markets have a way of
disappointing people most people end up
getting disappointed it doesn't work out
that way
and you know i even think that even if
bitcoin is going to make a big move
which i doubt i think is going to have a
much bigger shake out first i think
there's far too many people who have
lever up their bitcoin who have borrowed
against their bitcoin because they don't
want to sell because they're afraid of
losing out on the big gains but they
needed money and so they borrowed
against it i think this is an accident
waiting to happen even if i wanted to
buy bitcoin i'm going to wait until
everybody gets flushed out of this
market you know i want to see i want to
see microstrategy go under you know i
want microstrategy to sell their bitcoin
then maybe i'll consider buying
something i doubt it but at least from a
market timing point of view i want blood
in the streets right i ain't gonna buy
into a mania into a hype and i know
people try to say oh no this is still
the ground floor
uh-uh i knew about the ground floor i
had an opportunity to get on the ground
floor this ain't the ground floor this
looks nothing like the ground floor so
if i didn't get in at the ground floor i
sure as hell aren't getting in now
peter
i respect your deep conviction on never
capitulating i do respect that no
problem yeah that's you know go down
with the ship i got no doubt that you're
doing that
but don't say i but you know like i
won't even have to say i told you so
because you'll you'll think about me
but you know
listen well you know what just in case
you're wrong
you know
don't put all your money you keep
talking about how you got almost
everything in bitcoin you know you've
also like your whole life
revolves around it you need some
diversification
because see if you're right if bitcoin
really is going to go so high you don't
need to have so much of it a little bit
is all you need
put the rest of your money and this goes
for everybody else who has listened to
this podcast right and whether you want
my help or not right whether you want to
use your pacific asset management to
build a portfolio you want to go to
shift gold and buy some gold and silver
the matter but anybody that's listening
to this you know takes something off the
table
if bitcoin does do what you think it's
going to do you don't have to bet at all
don't bet the farm because if you're
wrong you're broke
so
take a good chunk of that bitcoin money
off the table and invest it in something
real something sensible that if you end
up being wrong on bitcoin you're not
broke you still have some assets that
will have value and if i'm right the
stuff that you're going to buy that i'm
recommending is eventually going to go
way up and it will more than make up for
what you lost in bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it